nobody has a clue what they are and so
you get somebody
[Music]
[Applause]
luke dominate here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we're in willow
alaska here with wayfinder kennels and
we've got mr linwood and miss kathy here
and we
are going dog mushing
are you guys ready yeah
all right
look at all those dogs
[Music]
her name's weasel
and she's an eight-year-old lead dog she
ran i did around with me two years ago
so her head needs to come right through
there
there you go
[Music]
there you go
hold him right there
hey guys are you excited
[Applause]
oh those dogs are so excited it's like
driving a muscle car if your car got
irritated at you for stopping at red
lights
i just watched a dog running on its
front two legs whilst doing the splits
and pooping
it was the most amazing thing
tommy says he can taste the dog farts
all of these dogs are part of gabe's the
actual race team and several of them
have run the dinner rod multiple times
yeah these dogs like to pull gabe's just
riding the brake
if he didn't ride the brake would they
just go bonkers um
yeah basically they're going to speed up
and go as fast as they want and i want
to control that speech
[Music]
check it out this is the parking brake
when your dog's sledding
all right we got afternoon traffic here
in alaska other commuters
so gabe just told me that these dogs
consume 15 to 20 000 calories when
they're in race mode that's why you
don't see fat sled dogs that's insane
i need to start pulling dog sleds i can
just like eat crispy creams like five
times a day
you see the dogs biting snow and eating
snow because they're so hot these dogs
are used to negative temperatures
okay what do you guys think is that
pretty cool yeah you're completely
warped
[Music]
all right toby you gotta ride tommy are
you excited
it's a good place to stop
[Music]
i think nathan's a natural born musher
and that comes from old mule driving so
gabe's teaching the boys the dog sled
commands g to go right hot to go left
and she makes a little kissy sound at
him but she wants him to speed up
[Applause]
[Music]
okay get up down further
here let me help you out there there you
go tom
i wanna sleep you gonna sleep i'm
exhausted
okay i'm ready
[Music]
there's mount denali the tallest
mountain in north america which is a
little over 20 000 feet
so these dogs move at a pretty good clip
they go between ten and a half to seven
miles per hour when they're doing an
endurance race like the iditarod that's
really fast for a thousand miles
hold on tight
at home stretch they can feel it don't
worry you can't get up here
[Music]
give these dogs a real nice workout
okay well take that off him
hang on here bud hang on hang on
all right it's time to pass out the
salmon snacks so they're nice little
filets of salmon right
hand it to him don't hold it back he's
going to snap at it if you pull it back
[Music]
i'm going to have one of you guys pull
here okay so we're going to have you
pull right here okay you want to run
push
this actually
keep going keep going keep going keep
going
holy dog whoa
that's 15 pounds of meat
and about four pounds of
beef fat
and the kibble's just a little left over
from breakfast how many pounds of food
do you go through a day
35 pounds of beef is this the entire
sled of dog food here uh this is for
linwood's group it is yeah
one meal one meal
and go get it it's like a good half okay
and there you go
this is good training if you guys ever
want to have dogs eli is also going to
get one and a half
[Laughter]
well for a long time nathan has told me
that his favorite animal in the whole
world is a huskies
is this pretty cool yes it's the best
day
ever
so do you want huskies you want me to
get you a bunch of huskies yes i want a
whole dog chain
this is gabe's racing sled here so for a
long distance running we have some
mandatory gear your first one's your axe
you have to have booties for every
single dog
all of my booties are bundled like this
what's the gun for why would we have a
gun in the sled
oh bears moose bears are hibernating
right they're not around
but you said moose
so moose are really really dangerous to
the dogs you guys might see mushers
working with their dogs pedaling and i'm
ski pulling and pedaling and ski pulling
and i'm literally helping the dogs we've
got our cooking pot here
and then we can put our fuel down inside
here so we'll light it off oh you just
put a little diesel in there or
something we use heat okay yeah so
isopropylene alcohol but i can load a
dog in here
and then they get
put in a sled we close everything up
they're in a nice safe spot
sled dog racing is really popular here
in alaska and there's lots of different
races but the big one is the iditarod
the official start of the iditarod race
is here in willow alaska and it goes a
thousand miles all the way to gnome and
right now the iditarod's going on and
they're just in the last few days of the
iditarod race
okay let me help you let me help you
there's a good slide look at that that's
a that's a fast one we got a few minutes
before dinner so the boys wanted to do a
little sledding on the hill behind the
house so we're gonna do some sledding
[Music]
it went far they got some distance
isn't that awesome
guys check out the grizzly bear yeah
[Music]
all right check it out we got some
dinner here
you guys hungry you know what those are
those are moose
like the burger yeah
best burger in the world yeah
i'm skinnier than that
the cranberry fluff is good
yes we got some blueberry
cobbler here this looks amazing
look at that
we've done some mushing we've learned
the basics we've got a belly full of
moose burgers and good food and we're
gonna we're gonna go out and do some
camping
here let's go
give me it and i'll help
[Music]
there you go
[Applause]
all right guys you ready
wow
[Music]
come on tom the dogs can pee while
running you should do
nathan you want to ride with me yeah all
right tommy you're gonna ride up there
you want to have eight of them don't you
yeah
[Applause]
welcome to camp this is where we're
going to be spending the night tonight
this is going to be really cozy and i am
so excited that i didn't have to set up
the tent
they got three of these arctic oven hot
tents and we got our own 10 over there
and that's going to be real nice those
tents are super warm and they got a
little picket over here for the dogs
gotta hold on tight the two had a job
sleep on
make sure you spread it out like that
all right and then he pees off
[Music]
we're gonna need a little bit more
insane you hanging out with double time
they got five gallon buckets to sit on
this is glamping man
the luxury stuff
bud cushions this is the man who's been
trained in the hospitality arts look at
this
oh yeah that's the good stuff
oh my goodness look at these marshmallow
sticks here this is professional grade
choose your weapons
i bet i could kill a deal with this you
could kill a deer with them
oh yep
we're sitting here by the fire and the
dogs are growling at something in the
shadows
okay i read call of the wild one too
many times we're about to be attacked by
wolves i've seen this i know how this
ends well it's getting a little bit late
guys so i'm gonna get the tent all ready
for the boys bed and uh
we're gonna get ready to get snuggled in
for the night
well i brought the boys bunk beds with
me so that we could all sleep together
in the same tent
and i'm just going to get this together
real quick yeah really well
there's your double decker
all code nathan you good are you warm
well guys it's late and we're all
cuddled into our sleeping bags in a nice
warm hot tent and this tent is heated
with a propane heater instead of a wood
stove like i have so we could just leave
this on low all night long and don't
have to fuss with it it'll keep us warm
all night long exhaust pipe out the top
so we don't have to worry about carbon
monoxide i'm going to turn off the
lights and go to bed but before i do i'm
going to set up a time lapse outside
you guys get to enjoy that i'll see you
guys
good morning it is brisk and chilly here
but it is beautiful
let's see how the dogs are doing
good morning guys it's funny those dogs
are so rowdy when we go to harness them
up but they were just quiet and calm all
night long
i'll go see if my boys are up yet
good morning toby how you doing
oh god
it's nice and warm in here huh
yeah we're only using like one burner
[Music]
there we go
oh deep down in there oh hey david
this is a bonafide musher cooker right
that looks like an old dog bowl
it is
we got a
frozen block of ice there
yeah put that in there that's our
you guys don't know what this is this is
bottles of heat it's what you put in
your car to keep the gas lines from
freezing so it's something that every
good alaskan has on hand yep
it's isopropyl alcohol not drinkable but
it burns very hot
that goes on here
all right
we're gonna heat that water up
and then we're gonna put our meals in
this is mousse sausage with peppers and
onions and cheese and eggs
it's already cooked oh pretty cool
so it just needs to get warmed up nice
and it's nice you don't have to worry
about keeping them frozen do you that's
living in a big refrigerator
nathan's so jazzed to go cuddle huskies
didn't get dressed
nathan really is built for winter
camping he's that kid's swarm
this dog really loves cuddles
which one's this i forget
aurora this is aurora
what'd you do well tommy it it looks
like none of the dogs were eaten by
wolves in the middle of the night yeah i
counted them that's well that's great
we've been obviously reading too many
jack london novels
you gotta give these fish
be quick about it before you irritate
them
is that gone already geez yeah hey boys
are you ready for hot chocolate
yeah
all right that's right you have to stir
it up okay it's all on the bottom
hard for me to get out the kennel it was
like
and do you guys want spoons or fork you
guys are going to eat like a race team
oh my goodness there's no time for
spoons and forks and plates you just
squeeze it out like
yeah squeezable yeah squeezable
breakfast burrito exactly
well that's good
yeah moose sausage right right yeah kind
of breaking down camp getting things
picked up slowly taking it easy
you enjoying the dog pit and dumb yes
all right gotta get our stuff packed up
and the cot put away
and i'm just sitting here cleaning up
and those boys are just over there
petting and petting and pet those dogs
aren't going to have any fur left on
them by the time those boys get done
[Music]
that's really good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
guys you know how far we did
we did 32 miles
five two and a half hours
hey nathan what do you think you still
want a husky yeah
yeah
guys thank you thank you so much gabe we
had just a great time i had a wonderful
time with you guys
and thank you so much definitely can you
come set up all my camps i i just
thank you so much we had such a great
time if you guys want a really authentic
dog mushing experience it's going to be
really hard to beat wayfinder kennels
here in alaska so definitely check it
out i'll put a link in the video
description below
tom
did you have a good time yes
listen i hope you guys had a good time
too if you want to see more videos from
the outdoor boys youtube channel make
sure to click subscribe we put out new
videos every saturday morning click
subscribe nailed it if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning and hit that bell
button and you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
all right get him with the tail
worth the tail
here tommy
here let me help you oh